this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday September 20th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
Washington and Beijing are at odds over
a number of issues including the
development of Advanced Technologies but
despite those tensions this year is on
track to be one of the strongest years
for investment flowing from China to
Silicon Valley
a new report shows Chinese investment in
U.S venture capital and private Equity
Funds is on Pace to reach around 880
million dollars this year that would be
the second highest it's been in more
than a decade and it's raising concerns
among U.S officials
so what's driving the flow of cash and
how might the US react
here to discuss this is our Venture
Capital reporter Heather Somerville
hi Heather thanks for joining us Hey Zoe
glad to be with you so huge sums of
money are coming in to the U.S from
Chinese investors who are the investors
behind all this funding and why is there
such interest in pouring money into
Silicon Valley now well there has been
interest for many years and the
investors on the China and are a range
of investors some are private
individuals looking to make a few bucks
on U.S startups some are Chinese
government entities government guided
funds Chinese corporations it really
does run the gamut on the one hand I
think there's plenty of investors who
are interested purely in a financial
return U.S tech has been a good place to
make money for some time now and U.S
Venture Capital firms that are taking
this Chinese money have often performed
very well over the last many years but I
think the point of writing about this
now is that there is tremendous concern
from the National Security community
government officials across agencies the
National Security analysts and people
who work on investment security that
these sorts of Investments offer the
Chinese ample opportunity for a range of
things that the US government really
doesn't want to happen that can include
overt IP theft from U.S startups
and it can include something that seems
a little bit more benign but is also a
national security concern and that is
the Chinese government gaining insight
as into how U.S startups are formed how
they're built how they scale how they
end up being successful Chinese
investors who put money into a bunch of
different companies in a particular
sector whether that's AI whether that's
semiconductors can get this aggregated
view of how a sector is developing in
the United States and this is what has
alarmed the Biden Administration and
National Security officials
so there are a couple points I want to
break down there first off how do U.S
government officials decide who's just
here to make money and who is maybe
looking for more information on U.S tech
or Insight on how the companies are run
Zoe I don't think they know the answer
to that question I think that's part of
the problem that's part of the challenge
and in talking to government officials
who work on this they were very explicit
that they have a huge blind spot in
identifying who are the limited partners
limited partners is the term we use for
the investors who put money into these
Venture Capital funds because they
aren't disclosed they're not press
releases about them they're really hard
to identify often intentionally shrouded
behind multiple funds so their identity
is concealed let's talk a bit about the
report who was behind it and what was
their goal the report was authored by
two researchers who have specialized in
Chinese geopolitical and economic
strategy and they have a small
consulting firm in the DC area and their
report was published through the
foundation for defense of democracies
which is a conservative leaning think
tank in DC that does published work on a
range of issues including China issues
and I think that they were trying to get
like some type of Top Line number
to raise attention to the volume of
money that is still coming from China
into U.S Venture Capital firms in spite
of what one would think are a lot of
reasons for that investment not to
happen half the funds that were named in
this report were any of the companies
that have received the money commented
about this yes so you can put them into
different groups
there's the big funds that people who
know Silicon Valley will know very well
Sequoia Capital light speed Venture
partners and they have China Affiliates
who have a ton of Chinese government
money and Chinese corporate money and
their comments are that their China unit
is totally separate from their U.S
operations if you talk to some of the
smaller firms their position is well
Chinese capital is just a really tiny
fraction of their fund you know one
percent five percent something like that
I will say though in speaking to
government officials for this story
something that they brought up was they
don't actually care how much Chinese
money it is they don't actually care
about the dollar amount what they care
about is what comes with that investment
do these limited partners want quarterly
meetings with the startups do they want
access to technology information like
what else is wrapped up in that
relationship and also do they have
particular influence over the Venture
Capital Partners who are deploying the
capital and this is something that the
Biden Administration is really focusing
on in part through an executive order
that came last week that tried to
refocus cypheus's efforts to identify
potential investment threats that
involved sensitive U.S Technologies and
cepheus just so listeners knows that
committee on foreign investment in the
United States it's a panel of
interagency Representatives who are in
charge of of reviewing foreign money
coming into U.S companies so Heather for
U.S tech companies and for startups who
might be receiving this money what
should they be looking at going forward
or should they be concerned at all I
think unfortunately there's only so much
that entrepreneurs can do I think they
should start by asking the Venture
Capital firms that they're in
conversations with about fundraising who
their limited partners are I don't know
if they'll get a straight answer is the
challenge I don't know if they'll get
the information that they need or they
want to make a decision but I just think
in general awareness for entrepreneurs
that where they Source the money
is really important to their long-term
success in the security and the
prosperity of the company that they're
building all right that's our reporter
Heather Somerville thanks for joining us
Heather thanks Zoe and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing if you want
more Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]